you are going to face pokémon gestritten
ob die play3 filmstars für die sich
gemeinsam mit luca und ich weiß nicht ob
ich hier für jetzt gefeiert oder
gehärtet werden
ich habe mich mal wieder so in den
weiten des internet herumgetrieben und
habe pokemon go für den pc entdeckt ich
verlinke euch ein video dazu in der
beschreibung von dem kanal die mails
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie man sich das
installiert aber es funktioniert
verdacht hockenheim die fahrt der
recorder wie etwa das ist jetzt dieser
standard links hier ich habe mir erst
mal neues profil kreiert ich bin
natürlich eine junge nehmen ihn jungen
wir machen das jetzt erstmal alles ein
paar sekunden später ich habe mir jetzt
diese pokémon typen kreiert und ihr seht
schon ich bin jetzt in der welt wirklich
drin und ich kann sogar rein und raus
kommen weils ihr euch fragt wo ich bin
ich bin in köln
ich weiß nicht ob man das irgendwie
sieht aber hier ist der rein und ich
habe jetzt einfach mal als vor drei
angegeben man kann auch sagen okay hier
locations setting die sache bei diesem
der sachen ist das ist natürlich in der
gewissen form eine art heck also ich
kann da theoretisch mich mit meinem
profil einloggen und da in der stadt
rumlaufe ist es allerdings nicht so ein
krasser heck dass ich sagen könnte ok
telepathie mich von da nach da und ich
bin direkt zehn kilometer gelaufen es
ist halt quasi einfach nur so als würde
man wirklich rumlaufen das heißt es geht
jetzt nicht dass ich mich jetzt nach
amerika setzte dann würde ich mich
gewarnt werden ich sage nachher noch was
zu dieser hack sache allgemein aber
jetzt fange ich mir erstmal ganz kurzes
thumann da hiervon was passiert wenn ich
die kamera anmache wohnort detektor von
station wird dir leidtun oft ja okay ich
mache einfach mal aus versuche jetzt
hier das kommando zu fangen wie great
okay das ist super wenn das team anders
auftritt wäre schon sehr traurig aber
wir haben es jetzt gefangen das ist
unser erstes pokémon klicken auf ok das
ist im pokédex registriert das ist
richtig schön ich bin bei meinem pokémon
global account auf dem handy bei dem
hier bin ich dem blauen gerade level 23
so circa die hälfte durch und meine
besten pokémon
sinn wenn ich die mal nach wettkampf
punkten sortiere diese hier die da oben
eingeblendet seht also coco bailamos und
ak nie
ich habe mir extra für das spiel hier
neuen account kreiert auch komplette
letzte abad dieser professor nick name
ich nehme ich einfach mal luca hacker
klicken auf ok vielleicht ist der name
noch frei wenn ich auf ok drücke ja okay
dass er nennt sich denn luca hacker was
schauen ob luca hacker 123 noch in
ordnung ist er müsste nämlich denke ich
klappen genau wurde kohl nickname
blablabla talk ist oft erklärt ist
erstmal das game ich glaube wir wissen
allerdings sie das ganze auch guck mal
wir können direkt auf einen zu greifen
hier ich kann uns jetzt hier so ein
keyboard ding ein will und dann seht ihr
schon weh ist im norden es für den
westen des für den osten und es ist für
den süden das heißt wenn ich jetzt
drücke passiert nichts also irgendwie
ist das w gerade darauf eingestellt dass
ich das ganze ein bisschen drehe dass es
irgendwie zoom ich weiß nicht woran das
liegt aber wir haben hier vorne ein
traum was wir uns mal kurze können
können sodass hauptsitz gefangen das
müsste auch ein denk safe drin sein bei
mir beim level ist mittlerweile so auf
level 23 kommen noch so wp 300 taxis die
allemal fliehen das haupt sie wurde
gefangen
das wird jetzt natürlich auch wieder im
pokédex registriert in der zeit wurde es
gemacht wird schauen ich mal eben ich
kann dazu nämlich entfernen dann kann
ich mir dieses gps ding als 2000 jahre
später hat freunde ich bin weg in
pokémon go ihr seht schon fett
eingeblendet wahrscheinlich so eine
fette anzeige von dieser app ich weiß
nicht ob die eingeblendet wird wenn ich
das mit fraps aufnehmen oder nicht aber
ich sehe gerade ganz fett im bild seine
lauf anzeige habe mir hier gerade schön
einhorn you gefangen klickt man einfach
auf enter und jetzt seht ihr schon kann
ich einfach mal weh gedrückt halten und
dann laufe ich durch die stadt und das
ist nicht irgendwie dass sich in die
richtung wo ich hingucke sondern das
bezieht sich auf
das hier oben auf die nord süden anzeige
ich kann auch auswählen jetzt
beispielsweise mit ob ich jetzt im auto
beispielsweise sein sondern wenn ich
jetzt wie drücke sich schon nicht laufe
relativ schnell kann jetzt nehmen bei
pokerstars mitnehmen weiterlaufen to
face pokémon gestritten ob die play3
film sari
ich nehme hier mal ganz schnell die
beiden cops mit nämlich museum ludwig
und drews die defizite oder so ich
glaube das ist dabei dem römischen
museum oder so ich mache mal wieder das
nicht so schnell bin wie jetzt
beispielsweise auf einem motorrad und
bewege mich am eingang zwei taxis
nachdem ich jetzt 4000 ob sie auch mein
gott apollo in meiner richtigen pokemon
version auf dem handy habe ich bereits
ein gängiger gefangen allerdings habe
ich noch ein polo auf level 800 oder so
das heißt es wird auch ein geiles gänger
ich bin level 3 und bewege mich jetzt
einfach mal hier zu den beiden
pokerstars ich habe fünf pokémon pokédex
befinde mich jetzt hier genau zwischen
zwei lockt modulen und kann erst mal
hier ich wollte nicht ändern ich wollte
dass poker stoppt den super einfach hier
raus und zwar muss ich nach dorthin
irgendwo weil sich dort was ist denn
hier der nächste sind tomate oder was
ich tue mir ebenso als welchen zug und
laufe mal eben da hinten zum rein weil
da vorne sind die kranhäuser und dort
weiß ich einfach aus erfahrung dass da
immer viel lockt module nahezu an sind
hier in die richtung hier natürlich an
den häusern vorbei hier an der arena
vorbei und hier laden schon die anderen
arenen diana da seht ihr jetzt freunde
drei lockt module sind ja an jetzt
pushen wir das ganze wieder runter als
welchen ganz normaler fußgänger und ihr
seht schon hier spawnen wieder pokémon
nämlich horn liu hong lei und roma
kommen wir packen man dieses hässliche
schweine dingen traumauto in meinen
achten auf die finger auf traumauto das
ist einfach richtig ekelhaft es hat ccp
drei fragezeichen das heißt es wird mein
bestes pokémon sein und hat
wahrscheinlich den cp von 50 oder so das
ist doch mal cool da hat man drei horn
you
an jedem einzelnen lockt modul man so
stellt man sich das doch vor das cool
ist halt einfach die leute sehen mich
quasi nicht als spieler dort sehen aber
wahrscheinlich wenn ich jetzt hier
locker rein packe aber wissen nicht dass
ich hier zu hause sitze und mir quasi
das lokal mit abgeschaut mal kranhäuser
habe ich meine natürlich ist es irgendwo
assi und ich denke dass viele das video
auch deswegen werden allerdings bin ich
ja nicht der entwickler von diesem hack
sondern ich spiele es ja nur und ich
meine wenn sie illegal wäre hätte
pokémon oder naja antic das
wahrscheinlich schon längst gebannt oder
so und selbst hier haben wir noch die
komischen terror war super cool so auf
dem pc dessen error wenn ich auf das
andere hollywood hier draufklicken
kriege ich die ganzen & error ich habe
gerade ehrlich gesagt ein wenig angst
dass mein account gebannt wurde
vielleicht hätte ich mich nicht luca
hacker nennen sollen ich laufe mal eben
zu den anderen beiden pokerstop sie vorn
und wenn ich jetzt beim drehen hier auch
in euro bekommen die werden nicht mal
geladen
fakt ist es weg ins feld login read
write account wenn ich auf read write
brücke wird es wahrscheinlich wieder
nicht funktionieren also ich denke mal
ich gucken ob ich eine e-mail bekommen
habe ich habe noch keine e mail bekommen
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt ich wurde
gebannt also freunde message des videos
macht das nicht spiele pokémon bauen
normal geht nach draußen aber macht
sowas nicht zum glück habe ich mir neue
konkret und nicht meinen alten das war's
von wieder meine damen und herren wenn
es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen wahrscheinlich
werden sehr viele leute denken weil die
sagen rosenhecke scheiße habe ich mal
meine meinung demgegenüber ist auch
negativ also ja ihr schreibt man bitte
in die kommentare heck
wenn ihr bis jetzt noch dran seid und
wollten wir auf musical instagram
gaddafi alles eine beschreibung
einschüsse hier